hey this is the reporting for geek
culture we are on the show floor of Xbox
here at e3 and I have with me today
stealing his precious time Eber who was
a product marketing manager for Seagate
and today you're going to be telling us
about this little product here Thank You
Z so this here is the game drive for
Xbox gamepad special edition right to
cherubi capacity storage for about 50
plus X plus 1 games now there's no what
this one is more awesome than the
previous generation is this is a gamepad
special vision so it keeps drive you do
get a one month free subscription to
Xbox gamepad which as you all know it
just announced two months ago and has an
expansive library of 100 plus game so 15
game storage plus one month the game
pass all the food it has a low cost of
89 nine dollars eighty ninety nine us so
fine your average consumer and I'm on
the market or you know expanding more
hard drive why should I be going to you
guys were going to skip money and
getting a cheaper version with you know
absolutely so with the design for Xbox
bags you go to things one of
verification from the Xbox team that
they have tested and approved and
verified that this drive is one someone
compatible with all Xbox one versions
including the brand-new Xbox one X in
addition so and we also match the design
to for you popular Xbox one s owners
there's a one to one color palette match
of the popular Xbox one apps so not only
does it work great great with your Xbox
one it also looks perfect next to your
white 1s and if I'm one of those
unfortunate if you don't have the funds
with this I hear that there's an
alternative way of getting it we're
going to doing a giveaway on the geek
culture website absolutely so to
generous because it's your inner like
absolutely so we are doing a giveaway
we're going to give people one of these
drives
I know back to my desk start pretty good
so aside from the game drive you also
have another lovely storm trooper
looking product over there and what is
this in your hand right now so this here
is a brand new game drive hub for Xbox
just announced this week at e3 brand new
fresh off the press what this is is a
massive 8 terabyte drive with two USB
ports in the front what this gives you
the capability to do is basically store
8 terabytes into your Xbox one keep the
installation and that's stored for about
200 plus games for massive library of
those you guys got a game shelf full of
games this is a drive for you
and in addition to it we also have these
two fancy ports here on the front so you
basically gives you the ability to
connect and user more controllers or
even charge your phone or even connect
another one of the two terabyte drives
that I just showed a second ago don't
you would be a 3.0 Drive there it is so
it's connected via USB 2 3.0 into your
Xbox and then the 2 ports in the front
also USB 3.0 high speed beautiful stuff
and we're also going to be giving this
one away on the key culture website so
again guys and girls if you want to get
your hands on it yeah check out the geek
coaching website scroll down the page
for more information of how you can
enter for a chance aggressive absolutely
look at winter